fanatical flames fanned by propaganda
sent tens of thousands of men to the
banner
of the so-called islamic state
thousands of women went to they are
always thinking about women
they are very obsessed with woman were
these isis brides and families drawn by
utopian dreams
and isis all free or medicine free
or did they share the ideology of a
death cult
this was never part of the plan the
wives of foreign immigrants to the
so-called islamic state
enjoyed a status above all others now
home is a refugee camp in a cell in
enemy territory curd held syria
raka was a magnet drawing in thousands
of volunteers to the capital of the new
so-called caliphate now it's a
battlefield
and many senior isis leaders have sent
their families out of the city
here in inisa four women suspected of
close ties to isis
are being held in a secure location
their husbands are under arrest
or still in raqqa aisha a syrian
is married to a moroccan he came to
raqqa before the caliphate was declared
two years ago
and she insists his aim was purely
spiritual
look all the immigrants when they came
to raqqa it's not fair
the purpose of fighting or war many
immigrants especially
from european countries they came
because
they can do islam and that's
a place it's not for war or for going to
military camps
they just want to live in a muslim
community
but it turns out her husband came to
deal in antiquities
stolen heritage used to fund isis
um and my husband was working in bruins
antica and
you know all things in french and spain
he's buying and selling such things
and that's that friend told him that
there's a good things here in raqqa and
you can't buy it from me in a good price
unwittingly revealing her husband's
financial connections
and his success within the tightly
controlled isis structures
aisha also let slip that she knew um
al hussein sally jones the convert from
kent who married the head of the digital
jihad junaid hussein
he was killed in a drone strike in 2015.
now aisha claims jones wants to come
home
did you meet many british people um i
see
one british woman she was amazing
brittany
and she lost her husband in a battle and
she has one boy
she's about 50 years and she's very cute
and
she was crying because she want to go
back to british and you know the united
states prevent her because she is
now a mercury wife and she told me that
she wished to go to her country
her friend fatima is a german immigrant
of lebanese descent
she's married to a german turk she
again insists that he was a civilian but
he emigrated to the caliphate more than
two years ago
and was wounded in an airstrike in mosul
this is where isis leaders were
concentrated
she fled an unhappy marriage at home in
germany to join him
after being groomed by him online
she now says that she feels manipulated
but she still loves her new husband
these women are being treated with deep
suspicion by the kurdish authorities
not so this group two years ago nine
women and five men
all connected by family ties chose to
leave jakarta
for a nation at war it's because i am
sick
i i i have to do surgery soon
and and my my money in indonesia it's
not not so
[Music]
and in an isis all free or medicine free
surgery free and we will get
a monthly monthly salary
because we are muhajir they they
promised to us
like that they they soon get get us out
me and my son to mosul to to get
all the surgery all the therapy
alhamdulillah my
son now cannot can walk but his autism
no it's not not better and me
i i get surgery alhamdulillah
yeah so it's why the youngest women seem
to take the lead in persuading the
family to leave
hypnotized perhaps by the utopian dream
offered by isis propaganda
when you see on the internet you see
the murder of jim foley the head cutting
of the western
journalists the people accused of
homosexuality thrown off
buildings this is a terrible behavior
yet you still came here that seems crazy
to me
you know first i have she have told to
you that
we have read all about isis
propaganda from the internet from
facebook tumblr
and etc and i have contact tool from
people from raqqa via tumblr do you know
tumblr
yeah i have contact with them with one
of them
he tell about us about the beautiful
things inside isis
and actually i'm i'm very afraid to see
that
video about cutting the head and
firstly i thought it's maybe it's not
from
isis maybe it's from the group who
the group who had isis like not isis
maybe
the other group when i indonesia i just
focus with the beautiful things
inside isis like they will give you a
very big monthly salary
and they will pay back your
journey costs from for example from
from jakarta to turkey to raqqa our
money
they will pay back our money these young
women were also groomed online
almost certainly by the unit headed by
sally jones
the head of isis female recruitment
there's a woman and the man in tumblr
well do you know who they were did you
ever meet them in real life never
just know them in internet because uh
after entering lost contact with them
lost contact in the end they claim
isis left them with a sense of disgust
especially
the advances from fighters did any of
you get married in
raqqa no they are very obsessed with
women like for example when i and
my father were walking in the market
suddenly
there was a man come to my father and
then he said
uh my father doesn't know who is who he
he is
and then hello so maycom how are you and
like that
do you know a girl a widow or a single
and my father's what you are
i don't know who and you come to me
suddenly just
my you see and that time it's a silly
things you know
it's very crazy it makes it make us
disgusting
their thing are woman woman married
and then after married for the first for
the second and the third and the fourth
i've just concluded my interviews with
the women who are married to people who
emigrated to join
the so-called islamic state and just as
we finished the interview american
intelligence agents have turned up
to subject them to cross-examination as
well
i think one of the things i can take
away from these interviews particularly
with the woman from germany is how
manipulative the islamic state can be
she was clearly groomed online as were
the girls
from indonesia with a dream of joining a
state that was a land of milk and honey
a very long way away
from the murderous uh death cult really
that we understand the islamic state to
be
this doesn't mean that these women who
were seduced with the dream
of a perfect caliphate are in any way
guilty of anything other than
total naivety some may face prosecution
here or at home
but in the meantime they wait in limbo
their fate still linked to those who
caused the catastrophe
of the caliphate in the first place to
men
sam kiley sky news inissa